hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in letter 47 sonaka is writing on
something to his friend lilius that to
us is a very
controversial topic and in his own time
other aspects of it were very
controversial as well as we see in the
letter and this is how people who are
slaves ought to be treated and we're not
going to candy coat this and say oh well
they're merely servants or you do have
to understand that when we're talking
about Greek and Roman slavery of the
ancient world we're not talking about
antibellum uh race-based slavery in the
United States I mean there is an
important difference between those but
as we see senica talking about slaves
were often treated in very terrible
cruel ways and it was an arbitrary way
of people having power over each other
now that said you can apply this advice
to all sorts of other matters where
there's some sort of power and Prestige
differential it doesn't just have to be
ancient slavery we could think about you
know bosses who act tyrannically towards
employees we can think about people who
are abusive within their own household
with their spouses or children we can
think about all sorts of power relations
that approximate to
servitude senica is congratulating his
friend for being a good master and what
that means is being in many ways less of
a
stereotypical Master as many Romans of
the time understood it he he talks about
living on familiar terms with slaves so
famili VI living not just acting not
just doing one thing but the entire
scope of your common life together and
then there's this really interesting
rhetoric IAL passage he's imagining
somebody arguing with him they are
slaves and then Senus says no they are
human beings hes right so yes they are
slaves they are in a position of slavery
but that's not what they are at their
Essence at their core first they're
human beings and only after that are
they slaves they are slaves no they are
housemates they are the people who you
live together with you just happen to be
in a dominant position in relation to
them they are slaves no they are
lowborn friends he uses the word amiki
there right and lowborn humiles it could
mean lowborn it could mean those who are
placed in an inferior position they are
slaves and here's where he gets to a
really important point that we're going
to come back to
no they are your fellow slaves you are
all slaves of one sort you just happen
to emphasize the power relations and the
ownership of another person but you have
the potential to be just as much a slave
as they are and he goes on and he talks
about uh Roman Masters and how they
typically treat their slave he says I
laugh at those who think it is beneath
them to share a meal with their slaves
why not there is but one reason it's one
of the traditions of arrogance for the
master to eat his dinner with a crowd of
slaves standing in a circle around him
he eats more than he can hold immense
greed loading his distended stomach a
stomach that's forgotten its proper
function merely so he can expend more
effort on vomiting than he did on
ingestion meanwhile the poor slaves
aren't allowed to move their lips even
to to speak every murmur is curtailed by
the rod by physical violence used
against them and you can read the rest
of the the discussion in this I I'm just
going to bring up a few the result is
those same slaves who cannot speak in
their Master's presence are ready to
speak about him to others a little bit
later he says I can hardly list all the
cases of cruel and inhumane treatment
which would be abusive to beasts of
burdens let alone to human beings when
we recline at dinner
one is wiping up gobs of spit another
crawling under the couch to pick up the
scraps the drunkards let fall a third
carves the expensive fowl he lives only
for the proper carving of of poultry
another is the cup Bearer decked out
like a woman and struggling against his
years he cannot Escape Boyhood he's made
to revert to it and he says his first
shift is devoted to his master's
drinking his second to his lust another
has been assigned to eval evaluate the
guests it's his task to stand there and
observe which are the flatterers which
cannot control their gluttony or keep a
watch on their tongues right so this is
a slave who's actually having to watch
human nature
debase and so he says you know this is
the the kind of people that Masters
think they cannot bear to dine thinking
it beneath their dignity to come to the
same table as his own slave and senica
is saying this is just ridiculous
you you Masters are worse people than
the slaves that you bend into all of
these you know terrible shapes and he
talks about slaves not just being
enemies but being made into enemies
Masters make their own enemies their
Hostess they also are transforming the
slaves into beast of burden and worse
than Beast of Burden because they're
they're knowledgeable about what's
happening to them into
uh as Aristotle called them and sold
tools right so senica says this is not
the way you should behave instead you
should keep certain things in mind and
one of them foremost is the contingency
of who happens to be a slave and who
happens to be a master a lot of people
when they have a position of power or
social status or pick whatever else you
want over somebody else
they mistakenly think that somehow they
deserve it if they were born into a uh
family with a lot of power or Prestige
or wealth they think ah I am this sort
not realizing that every one of those
things could disappear and that
reversals can take place these are mere
matters of Fortune as Sena would say and
he reminds uh lilus and all of us
reading these letters reflect if you
will the person you call a slave was
born or arose oror out of the same seeds
as you enjoys the same Sky breathes
lives dies just as you do they are
fundamentally and foremost a human being
before being a slave even if they were
born into
slavery that's what really matters for
senca uh he also points out that anybody
can end up as a slave and this is one of
the important differences between
race-based slavery say in the American
South and the slavery that we see all
across the Mediterranean world and
indeed in most ancient societies that
developed past a certain point anybody
could become a slave you could become a
slave by going into debt and having your
debts uh bought out by somebody who now
you're a slave to you could become a
slave through Warfare he gives a whole
bunch of examples here he says that um
at the time of varys's disaster many
Highborn nobles were laid low men who
looked forward to a senatorial career
after their military service luck made
one of them into a Shepherd another the
guardian of a Hut The Fortunes of of
those you despise may come upon you you
at any time the position you hold the
prestige that you have the good name
that you have the wealth that you have
the connections that you have all of
those could go away you could wind up in
a as a slave and sometimes slaves will
become Masters another thing that didn't
happen in the American South but did
happen quite often in ancient
Mediterranean Society he goes on and he
says um every time that you remember the
extent of power over a slave remember
your own master has that same amount
over you but I have no master you say
well you're still young maybe someday
you will and he gives a few examples
don't you realize how old hecuba was
when she became a slave don't you
realize how old cus was now cus was the
king of Lydia one of the richest men in
the world he fought against the Persians
under Cyrus the Great Lost and became a
slave the mother of Darius Plato
diogenes Plato was taken captive by a
tyrant and essentially he wasn't
officially a slave but he's living at
somebody else's behest diynes was
actually taken by Pirates and sold as a
slave so it's it's a possibility for any
one of us he's telling us right now um
this idea about
Masters jumping ahead a little bit in
this we may not have physical Masters
acknowledged Masters but it's possible
for all of us to actually already have
Masters he says and this is in section
17 um show me a person who isn't a slave
one one person is a slave to lust to
sexual desire that is what motivates
them that is what drives them that is
what forces them into making humiliating
decisions that may in fact get them in
all sorts of trouble another is a slave
to Greed to wanting more and more and
more it could be money it could be
possessions it could be whatever you
want another ambition they want to have
power they want to have Prestige they
want to be famous they want celebrity
they need other people to say good
things about them if from the stoic
perspective you are being fundamentally
driven by these things you are already a
slave you are not actually free you can
own a house and have hundreds of slaves
under you but those things are driving
you and you're just as much a slave as
any of them perhaps even more so because
they can have free Minds he talks about
being a slave to other people just to
give a few examples of
this an ex-consul who's a slave to a
little old lady a wealthy man who is a
slave to a servant girl I will show you
young men of the best families who are
the vassals of pantomime dancers and
then he concludes with this really great
observation no servitude no slavery is
more shameful Tor and shameful here
doesn't just mean oo embarassing or
something like that Tor has the sense of
moral
degradation right and notice what else
he says then that which we take on
willingly and here he uses the term
voluntaria of our own will we choose to
take on this slavery we choose to be
slaves so if that's your casee you don't
have anything over the people that you
happen at this point in time to have
power over you're in fact perhaps more
of a slave than them just to go back to
the unfortunate cup Bearer right uh he's
a boy only at the party in the bedroom
he's a man he's being compelled to
satisfy the gluttony the desire for
Prestige and the lust of the person
who's driven by all three of these and
you know even though what he does is uh
from the outside degrading if he has a
free mind perhaps he's less degraded
than the
master senaka is going to sketch out for
us what he takes to be a better model
his own approach to those within his
household and what he takes to be that
of uh L Lucius but also that of as he
says um earlier Romans
and how they uh treated people
so what is this this better model to
live mercifully Clement right with
clemency senica actually wrote an entire
treaties on how one would do this and
amicably in a way with allies you could
say with people that you're going to be
with you should live that way with your
slaves you should structure your life
this way with these people who you share
a household with so what does that mean
he gets a little bit more specific
include them in conversation allow them
to actually speak right don't sew their
lips up by either physically or by
threatening them
um include them in planning treat them
as if they actually have Minds that can
be used useful include them in meals and
he talks quite a lot about this uh he
says don't you know what our ancestors
did to eliminate M resentment towards
Masters and to eliminate abuse towards
slaves they used the name father of the
household for the master and household
members for the slaves they instituted a
holiday when Masters would share a meal
with their slaves not just to do so at
that time but that it was the custom on
that day in particular they allowed
slaves to hold offices and pronounce
judgments within the house for they
considered the house to be a polity in
miniature by the way this Echoes what
Aristotle says in the nicoman ethics and
as well you could say it to a certain
extent in the politics about the
household the oos that it should be
understood not as a tyranny a despotism
of a master over
servants but rather a structured polity
a political Association in a smaller way
and then you know he he uh deals with an
objection that's going to come up so
wait a second you're going to let stinky
slaves come in from the stables and sit
down next to you and eat and senica says
well yeah not in every single case as a
matter matter of fact there may be some
people who have jobs that are you know
nice don't get them all sweaty and stuff
like that but they don't actually
deserve a place at the table except to
learn how to behave as a decent human
being he says shall I admit all my
slaves to my table no more than you
admit all who are free there's plenty of
free people who you wouldn't let eat
with you cuz they're jerks cuz they're
disgusting because they haven't mastered
what it means to be a human being he
says that you're wrong if you think I'm
going to exclude some on the grounds
that their work is less clean I will
evaluate them not by their jobs
Ministeries the things that they happen
to be assigned as their task I will not
evaluate them by that but instead by
their character morus now moribus is a
term it's the plural of M which means
something like a custom a habit a a
temperament a way of being a disposition
and you put all of them together and you
get somebody's character so being greedy
being lustful those are parts of a
character those are uh in this case
mores that you would judge a person
according to and this is by the way most
is the term that's used to to translate
the Greek ethos which we use to to get
the word ethics right moral Mor it
ethics both come from these terms we
evaluate somebody on their moral
character not on the job that they
happen to have been stuck with and
assigned and so this provides us with a
very important Criterion he does say
though that um let some dine with you
because they're worthy of dining with
you others to make them worthy so even
if somebody doesn't have a good
character them spending time with you at
the table this is where the clemency the
mercy comes in allows them to see like
how people behave with each other and
how they ought to behave themselves so
he's going to say uh to to bring this to
a close it's
important to uh let your slaves respect
you rather than fear you these two
different types of motivation and so C
is is the term there and it literally
means to cultivate it means to care for
to respect you allow those who are your
uh subservient uh servants slaves in
this case to do their task towards you
you're not saying ah everybody's
completely equal I can do everything on
my own but you leave it up to them
rather than forcing them through fear
Tim right um you don't want them to be
motivated solely by that because as soon
as they stop fearing you they're not
going to respect you at all as a matter
of fact it's difficult to respect and
fear at the same time and senica is
going to say um this is because respect
and love are connected together he says
um yeah here we go one who is respected
is also loved and love and fear do do
not mix thus I think you are doing the
right thing when you prefer not to be
feared by your slaves and when you
correct them because you will have to
correct them at times everybody needs
correction including those who happen to
be lucky enough to be a master when you
correct them only with words why whips
are for training speechless animals
violence and the threat of violence is
not a sufficient way to produce good
character which is what you're looking
for in people that you're going to be
living with so Sena doesn't suggest
getting rid of the institution of
slavery many people fault him and the
other stoic philosophers from the
ancient period for that but what he is
sketching out here really does reflect a
very different attitude and
understanding of
slavery uh than many other people of his
time had and he is suggesting it as not
just an alternative model but the right
model for the relationship between the
people who for the time being happen to
be Masters and those who happen to be
slaves how they ought to live together
on familiar
terms